says exercises leg circles
okay so these leg circle exercises are
another great exercise to practice when
you're taking your kimmy from sawadee
waza the seated position a lot of times
you're going to get knocked over and the
ability to control your legs from this
knockover position is really useful so
in this exercise what we're going to do
is we're going to start a regular seizo
you're going to sit off to one side
after you sit off to one side you're
going to balance yourself on your butt
as you bring your legs over to the other
side then you're going to practice
popping up on that side then we'll come
off on that side circle our legs back
the other direction and come up this is
good for your core good for your hip
flexors it takes a lot of strength
to do and plus it's going to be really
great for you when you're getting
knocked around taking your kidney and
says up so the ability to get knocked
over and control yourself back up to the
other side is very useful
leg circles